would you like a piece of a 1.5 trillion
dollar industry well i hope your answer
is yes because you want money for the
mission that you're on and if you are in
the health and fitness space then that
is your reality if you create a youtube
channel that grows into a successful
business you get a piece of a 1.5
trillion dollar industry and my guest
today is ben azadi who is a part of that
industry on youtube he's going to be
sharing his five tips for how he grew
his youtube channel into a full-blown
business
my name is heather torres and i am the
host of the youtube made simple show
where we are helping you overcome your
fear build confidence and create and
launch a successful youtube channel now
my guest today ben azadi is one of our
success students from our academy video
ranking academy and i'm so excited that
he's here today to talk about the five
steps he took to growing his youtube
channel into a full-blown business now
let me tell you a little bit about ben
benazzotti is the founder of keto camp a
global brand bringing awareness to
ancient healing strategies such as
ketogenic dieting and fasting he is the
best-selling author of four books
including his newest book ketoflex he's
on a mission to help one billion people
and he's doing that through his business
keto camp his youtube channel with over
six million views and one of the top
rate health and fitness podcasts keto
camp
[Music]
well i am so excited to bring to you
today my friend ben azadi who is uh
growing a successful youtube channel in
the health and fitness space and we're
gonna break that down today ben because
we have a lot of people who are
interested in figuring out how do they
grow their health and fitness channels
and so we're gonna walk through five
steps that you took to grow this channel
today but for those who are just meeting
you tell them a little bit about who you
are and what you're doing on youtube
yeah heather thanks for having me so ben
azadi's my name i'm the founder of keto
camp camp with the k
best-selling author of four books the
mission at keto camp is to educate and
to inspire a billion people so we have
our youtube channel that we launched uh
going on three years now to get the
message out there to the masses and uh
that's we're gonna talk about today i'm
so excited and three years so first off
we'll just start with saying that it
takes some time it doesn't just happen
overnight right but what you've been
able to accomplish from this is really
allowing you to um speak around the
country to write these books to create a
membership program with a thriving
community
and so we're going to walk through how
you did that but first i want to know
how did you actually decide on keto
because a lot of people come to youtube
and they go well i want to do health and
fitness how did keto become the main
piece of what you're doing how did you
decide on that niche
in 2008 i was obese 250 pounds broken
broken mentally obese and also
physically obese so i went through a
health transformation nine months i lost
80 pounds went from physically obese to
being physically fit physical six-pack
to mental six-pack so i had this whole
transformation but i still wasn't
necessarily healthy so i wanted to
figure out what health was so i explored
different diets and nutrition plans
vegan et cetera and then i came across
keto in 2013 and it really was
interesting to me i just loved learning
about it and sharing about it
at that time my company was called shred
fat
which is not very niche if you will
and about four years ago three and a
half years ago i hired a marketing coach
to help me build my brand and he first
thing he said is gotta get rid of
shredder fat
i'm like no i've been building this for
eight years now i've put so much energy
into it he says look if you listen to me
you're gonna grow much faster we gotta
niche down he said what do you love to
talk about what lights you up
what do you energize after having a
conversation speaking about and i said
well keto so that's where keto camp
spawned and then that's where we
launched the new channel and i believe
that was the right thing to do and it
really accelerated my growth because the
rich is true
the riches truly are in the niches yeah
and you know we've seen this experience
over and over and over i had uh rob
built he does tiny homes so he's not
just talking about real estate he's
talking about tiny home real estate and
you're doing the same thing rather than
just health and fitness rather than how
to lose weight it's about the specific
way that you're doing that and when you
go so deep a lot of people would say oh
but that's too niche right did you fear
that and how did you decide that that
was not the direction that you were
going for it i had a lot of pullback in
the beginning because i love talking
about other things i want to talk about
sleep i want to talk about mindset i
want to talk about fitness
and basically it was yes eventually i'll
get there but i gotta grow this audience
and focus in on this niche first and
then expand and it made a lot of sense
to me that's what a lot of people do
it's what you guys teach
so um i love talking about keto and i
know i could talk about it forever but
eventually i got to a point where my
audience was growing and then i could
sprinkle in the mindset and then i could
sprinkle in the fasting and the sleep
and all that other stuff oh that but
please take that youtube made simple
show listeners because that is a huge
piece you wanted to talk about all those
things but you were reserved you decided
to just talk about one thing and that
helped you to break through and i think
if more creators took that advice and
did that they would actually start to
see growth happen faster because they're
actually playing the youtube game right
right youtube wants people to come to
the platform to click on videos and to
watch them and if you're doing different
types of videos all the time it doesn't
know how to categorize you so when you
came in you came in with that mission
exactly yeah and i've sprinkled in
videos in the beginning i'm like i'm
gonna go against what i just learned i'm
gonna throw in a video i'm like mindset
and the view count was just so
low compared to the other videos and
you're right because youtube doesn't
know how to put that in the algorithm
i'm talking about keto keto keto and
then i'm talking about like john maxwell
it's like what do i do with this and
then it just tanks yeah yeah yeah so you
got to play the youtube game right so
the first thing you did was you picked
your niche the second thing you did was
actually started to study youtube and
really understanding that when you get
around people who are doing youtube when
you start to study youtube that's
actually where growth can happen too
yeah so in the beginning the way that i
launched my youtube channel was looking
at other creators in my space
and what are the videos they're doing
that are crushing it like filtering it
by most popular and then just putting my
twist on it and recreating those videos
and i was kind of like guessing at
things using tubebuddy and just copy and
pasting tags and i didn't really have a
structure of course and then i listened
to youtube secrets from sean and benji
and then i enrolled into the video
ranking academy and then now i had a
structure now i had actual like a
step-by-step structure so that's where i
got strategic with it and ever since i
did that not only was it easier for me
because i knew what i wanted to do but
my channel just took off because of
studying it looking at what you're doing
and how you teach it with your system
well thanks ben that's so nice of you to
say yeah but you know that's i think
something that a lot of creators miss
they're like let me grab all the free
content from random people or the idea
that it's not in the right order right
and that is when you can compress
decades into days and say no no don't do
that do it this way in this order um
that's where you can start to see
success right because you're in a
community that's understanding how that
works exactly yeah that'll accelerate
your results it did for me yeah so um
you first figured out your niche you
were learning from uh experts on how to
do youtube and then you started
delivering weekly content talk about
that first couple videos that you did
how did you decide to do those and then
what is your consistency been so far in
the beginning i committed to releasing
two videos per week and that could be
one video if that's what your bandwidth
is for me at that time was two videos a
week i completed 10 videos before i even
launched the youtube channel so i had a
little bit of my arsenal so i wasn't
scrambling so monday friday monday
friday and then i would think of
questions i was being asked for my
clients
i would go on google i would go get keto
magazines and look at some of the
articles and this would give me just a
whole bunch of ideas to create content
with of course that got a little bit
more advanced with what i learned from
you guys answer the public and all that
but in the beginning it was just doing
some searches on on youtube and google
and getting keto magazines so good so a
couple things to take away there you
didn't just make one video you made a
couple videos so that you could be ahead
because life happens
yeah so 10 views that's ambitious 10
videos i mean i think the first time
when i made videos i made two because i
was like i didn't want to be in front of
the camera it was all new um so make
more than one video uh i loved how you
said you did magazines and i think this
is an underrated magazines and blogs are
such a great place to find content and
here's why i i love them one magazines
people pay a lot of money to have
writers and editors on a magazine to get
the best content out there so they're
paying to make sure the best content is
going out there so recreate the best
content right and then blogs blogs are
usually structured in a way where people
have already done the research so all
you're doing is putting your own spin on
the things that people have already done
that's something that people don't
realize they can do it's like yeah
somebody made some a video very similar
with the same topic but it's your spin
your research your personality and
nobody has that but you yeah so i have
so many videos that are similar to other
keto creators but it's my research and
my personality which is unique to you
yeah and a lot of times when i'll make
videos i will say i read this blog and
i'm gonna walk through the steps they
talked about and i'm gonna add my pieces
in so that it's i can reference the
person that did the work but it is it's
my spin and and allows for that to
happen so really good uh take away on
that one so then you started doing the
weekly content ambitious starting with
two videos a week
but you were ready for it because when
you commit to something you commit to
something that's right um and then you
started creating you so you created
something free
and then after they got the free thing
you then
gave them the opportunity to go deeper
into the programs that you had created
yeah so i created a like an ebook a
freemium it's a free guide 12 pages
really basic just a lot of analogies
explaining what keto is they gave me
their name and their email for that pdf
on my email list and then i wanted to
get them from there to my paid course
and that was the progression of it
so on youtube are you selling your
course on youtube
not no very rare that i share sell it on
youtube yeah i think a lot of times
people think well if i have something
i'm going to sell then i have to talk
about it on youtube why do you go the
long route why do you
do the free video to the free thing then
into your program i want to develop more
trust with them
i want them to get the free version of
it and kind of like the framework but if
they want to go deeper then they would
come into my academy so um i will if i'm
doing a live stream on youtube and
somebody asked me if i do any health
coaching i'll say not one-on-one but
here's my academy but it's not something
i
it's not a goal of mine to sell the
course on youtube
i i we do that here at think media um
you'll probably notice that ben is
you've already mentioned we have video
ranking academy it's the best online
course for youtube creators but we
rarely actually talk about it on youtube
we want to allow people to see that they
can trust us with free content that they
can be a part of our world and we're not
here to sell them something but we do
have something to sell um if they want
to go deeper and become serious i've
been a video ranking academy member for
two and a half years also inner circle
and i've done a lot of youtube courses
i've done you know i'm not going to name
names other people out there i've read
other books but this is the most
comprehensive one the seminar system i
always go back there and i'm always
learning new stuff it's the most
complete youtube system i've ever done
personally well thanks ben you can be on
my show any time i'll also of course
because i i'm a living experience i love
that and um yes you can be on any time
that you want to talk about the success
you're having uh because of um youtube
now the last thing that you did as you
were growing your keto channel was that
you actually increased your uploads what
made you decide to add more to it and
then what types of videos did you add
so six months into it i had 342
subscribers which is less than what i
had my goals that i wanted to hit so i
was a little frustrated a little
discouraged having 342 although that's
awesome if you have 342 subscribers i
mean that's 342 people who are like yeah
i want to learn more
um but i was a little frustrated and
discouraged but i committed using that
word that you said earlier i wasn't just
interested in growing my youtube channel
i was committed so i said i'm just going
to keep doing it and sooner or later you
know the universe will break and i'll
get the what i need to do and reach the
people i need to reach so a video took
off five keto fruits you can eat all the
time i saw it just skyrocket on off the
charts on youtube my video and then i
just doubled down created more videos
five vegetables you can eat all the time
five keto not to eat all the time so i
started using a lot of these numbers
ahead of my videos
so good and then you also added in uh a
video podcast so how did you decide that
that's the direction you wanted to go to
add in that extra video podcasts are
great um i launched the podcast about
seven or eight months after the youtube
channel it was just too much bandwidth
for one person to do both yeah my coach
actually told me at that time he's like
what do you want to do first the podcast
or the youtube channel i'm like let's do
both he's like choose one
it's like all right let's do youtube
yeah and it was a great idea because
since youtube started to take off the
podcast when it launched it did so much
better because of youtube
youtube i'm on all social media
platforms you know that tick tock
instagram all of them are growing but
more people say i saw you on youtube i
found you on youtube i meet him in the
streets i i know you from youtube more
than any other platform out there like
all roads lead to youtube for me and
it's exactly what you guys teach so yeah
video podcast is great because you
always talk about this the guest is
creating your content yeah you just come
up with the questions and the structure
like you're doing here but the guest is
actually the person creating your own
content for you and you get to tap into
their audience it's just a win-win it is
it's such a win-win and i
and it's scary though right if you've
never interviewed someone before you're
like what do i ask how what what what is
this going to turn out talk about that
fear going into actually becoming an
interview show
i i take pride in my in my interviews so
i i do research like a lot of research
ahead of time i want to wow the person
that i'm you know interviewing so i want
to know their backstory i want to know
some of the challenges they've had and i
want to bring it up in the conversation
so as long as you do your research
you're going to have an amazing
conversation but the episode is not
about the recording is not about you or
me it's about the person so let them
share their story highlight them and
what they're doing it's really putting a
spotlight on them and people love that i
mean it's one of the best ways to create
relationships as you know because you
could reach out to garyvee and say i'd
love to go on zoom and pick your brain
you're going to get no reply but if
you're like hey i have this podcast i'd
love to bring you on more likely for
garyvee to say yes to that than just a
zoom call with you oh that was such a
good uh truth bomb right there because
more people should see the opportunity
with youtube uh the last thing that you
added also was going live you're going
live on your youtube channel and people
that is scary it was so scary for me the
first time ben the first time i went
live
i messed up the hook we teach always
have hook content and a call to action i
completely bombed the hook here's what i
did i was like we're gonna do that again
i clicked stop deleted the video and
then just started the live again that
was my first ever live on youtube so
tell me about how it was for you when
you started going live i've never done
that but
uh it's it's weird right yeah it's
camera there's no eyeballs i can't see
you breathing it's just a device right
it's just a weird situation but the
frequency creates the genius
in the beginning
i said i'm gonna do a live stream every
wednesday at 12 p.m eastern time on my
youtube channel it's been two and a half
years since i committed to that i've
only missed two wednesdays in two and a
half years and the only reason i missed
it because i lost my voice
that's it so everybody knows wednesday q
a or some sort of topic
in the beginning it sucks it's very
uncomfortable but you just keep showing
up keep embracing that suck and that
formula of success is suck suck suck
suss just keep embracing the suck and
showing up so good so what is ahead for
you now that you're growing this empire
on youtube are you gonna stick with
youtube what is the what's the next
level for you on youtube youtube is
number one
absolutely and youtube is growing as you
guys teach so even though you know tick
tock is blowing up for me and all my
other platforms are growing the main
focus is youtube because something that
i do on youtube is i could get a 10
minute video on youtube and create 15
other posts on other social media
websites from one youtube video so the
goal is to get to more subscribers
educate more people the overall mission
is to educate and to inspire a billion
people and youtube is the number one way
to do that right now i'm so excited
there's over a billion people on youtube
so you could reach them then i'd love
that well where can people go if they
want to learn more about keto if they
want to follow follow your youtube
journey um and they want to just connect
with you on social
youtube.com ketocamp or just type in
ketocamp on youtube it's camp with the k
subscribe right away and hit the bell so
you're notified of a new upload or a new
release so when you do your youtube
videos say what i just said
to your people subscribed uh benzali.com
has all my social media and information
on there and amazon has all my books
amazing well thank you so much for being
a part of this episode ben thank you for
your time thanks for coming to the
studio so fast i love the studio so fun
and i love that you know uh first it
started as you know just a a person who
bought our courses but i truly believe
that we are creating something together
and it's just so cool to see success
students you know coming on the show and
and being here and i'm just so grateful
that you did the work that you committed
to um the journey on youtube and i can't
wait to see what happens next so
grateful for you and your team thank you
so fun
well i hope that conversation was value
to you and i want to let you know that
today's episode was brought to you by
win this tech.com this is where we are
giving away a complete youtube studio
all you need to do is go to
winnistech.com
fill out the simple survey that takes
about five minutes and it will help us
know the exact videos that you want us
to make here at think media when you do
this you'll be entered in to win the
entire youtube studio that's the camera
the lighting the microphone and so much
more so go to winthistek.com today to
enter into that giveaway thank you so
much for watching today's episode i'd
love to know your takeaways what was
your aha moment let me know in the
comments down below and i'll catch you
in the next episode bye
you